I mean I know the trip isn't real life
but you know where you're doing all
those voices all the time when you were
filming this do you have to be really
strict with yourself and gotta go I'm
only doing Stan Laurel I know it's a bit
it's fun enough when I start to do more
serious acting rather than just being
stupid all the time it's just been very
good for me but Minh I got was from
Stephen Frears when I did Philomena all
he ever did was when I was being too big
he just look at me and go Steve bring it
down
so all I do is just not not be big and
not hang around Rob Brydon actually that
that the people in your Canon are you
adding to it all the time or who's in
your can I don't I don't really I mean
my impression stop around some Neil
Kinnock which shows you how long since I
actually practiced impersonation so I
can only do sort of I mean I can only do
people from people in I remember Ronnie
Corbett oh I used to do Ronnie Corbett
in vegan in Vietnam there was you know
in the jungle from the bushes
remember the Vietcong
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so do you still do Sly Stallone yeah hey
sue routine about Sly Stallone and Alan
Bennett in the same film which was I'm
actually being able to reuse this yeah
you see so my sister I'm sort of saying
you know do lot of swearing like that
just have one of those days Oh mother
loving came out of Buster's asked what
about you I have one of those days what
about you Alan yes I've had one of those
days except it was a cordless shot for
the packets of lemon puffs and I came
back with happy faces
[Applause]
[Music]
you